yeah welcome to this video playing el
camino from Sweden to academy on our
game we had a game don't see that too
often our queen f3m of course I have
work now this is plate 96 I've I think
but what now yeah this is one of them
problems with the one year five year so
loved very often know that what your
opponent is playing is not so great but
you still need to remember why hmm yeah
yeah probably this is not the best move
but I don't want to fall too far behind
on the clock I could give a check here
and your Queenie form something like
that yeah but it's not necessary yet
it's paolo e fibers is liability but
also limiting my plane maybe I should
have given the shag amp like we G from
yeah i can actually can do that i'd like
to get the Queen's off
and in this position I can cast the law
of course yeah I lost lost lots of time
yeah okay it's not great but check
really okay I don't mind that too much
why didn't why did he take I don't turn
and Rudy see who I ok or C 5 yeah he's
got 94 and night g5 as possible moves ok
I control d 4 1st c5 is a good move
anyway an ID g5 for example after the
capture only six I tell it doesn't feel
very dangerous to me ok so now let's
prevent it now it's knight has zero
ideas to go somewhere that can go we can
try night h4 f5 or what he could try to
try to target the c5 power 92 b3 Bishop
f2 something like that but I can get the
King all the way up to c6 I think
protect see five if necessary ok now my
next moves our Bishop e7 completing
development and then maybe maybe oh this
is interesting I wants to go to d3 this
is a good idea reli Clea good idea
okay I'll try to to go to 26 maybe
neither form maybe night f-for intending
to take and rook f7 and 95 okay but all
night f4 I can't play Bishop g5 if
everything else fails I can do that
interesting
interesting play
ok now the night has got a nice locating
locating Roland III mmmm Jim but it's
not clear that this hurts me so much all
right but I want to get out of the
default this is just too creepy all the
time standing up opposite this rook
maybe there is no one concrete problem
but still don't want that ok maybe I can
threaten if I up ok he will move the
King anyway and all the way back even
mmm yeah I'd like to play if i pay for
but I don't think I'll manage maybe this
is a way to activate okay we can go nite
a form yeah it's very difficult to to
make any substantial progress here
this is also not leading to much but
down it feels like um yeah this isn't
dangerous for me but I'm not sure if I
can do something
hmm yeah very difficult to make any
progress I can I can take play h3 and
I'm never going to lose this position
but how am I going to try for a win
hmm i don't really see how maybe maybe
just keep it simple
and go age three
Kim this is the simple solution where I
don't have any problems at all but maybe
maybe I'm active enough to set him some
problems but I don't really don't really
believe it
yeah this is this is quite passive but
it's it's enough to keep the balance I
don't really have some some great idea
young difficult
I don't really have anything to attack
with rooks on d2f to hand the bishop on
h2 it's everything's it's protecting
each other and where am I going to to
attack him I don't really see how he's
not moving though not sure why maybe I
can okay let's uh let's exchange one
pound and see if I can maybe some
somehow activate the king it is still on
oh I don't don't know I don't know I
don't think I would have allowed this to
be honest this some kind of
transformation but maybe it's not a big
deal
yeah it's probably probably nothing
check
26 seconds am I don't really don't
really see how to to do anything
constructive time morning I go D to
check if you move the rook check
hmm grah offered check I had offered the
droid Wi-Fi guy that what the dry i
think it was a draw but no I won on time
I had eight seconds against two we
actually had repeated already and I'm
not quite sure probably it's just dead
okay here with no time on the clock not
sure what what's happening schacter in
fact this is winning for me this is
funny yeah yeah well yes this one check
it looks really dangerous or this but I
have half the Queen next move and if he
goes something like that I have this
check which is important yeah it was
just nothing and not nothing much going
on very solid probably an around here I
must do something else not take on that
form but I didn't really find a good
good idea how to how to continue and
this is just a very safe solution but
probably a solution that should win
again alright thanks for watching